as spring gets into full bloom the
wedding season is beginning to take off
the average cost of a wedding in the
u.s. is more than $26,000 more than
1,200 of that is spent on flowers meg
Oliver shows us a startup company
helping people nip rising wedding costs
in the bud hey good morning good morning
most couples set a budget for their
wedding but more than half increase it
once they start planning flowers can be
one of the reasons but to Millennials
have found a way to help Brides cut that
cost on a day when a bride needs
something old something new something
borrowed and something blue
a new startup is offering all of the
above at a discount rene McKiernan
wasn't planning to have flowers at her
wedding the cost of weddings is
astronomical
the thing with the flowers is they are
beautiful they are one of the biggest
expenses of a wedding and they're so
wasteful until she heard about bloomer
end they didn't look like they were
secondhand flowers bloomer at an online
marketplace pairs of people willing to
share centerpiece arrangements to save a
few bucks for event B I'm taking a bud
vases from event a about a hundred and
moving them into larger vases the first
bride picks out her flowers and gets a
ten percent discount for sharing them
with a second bride that second bride
saves 40 to 60 percent by using those
same flowers a day or two later in
between events the flora spruces
freshens and rearranges all we're gonna
do is judge and rearrange and pick up
the bad things so McKiernan paid just
eight hundred and fifty dollars for the
same flowers that costs the first bride
seventeen hundred dollars
denis do you still remember your wedding
flowers yes what were they like
they were roses hydrangeas this
beautiful cream white color and a lot of
greenery around it um and they were very
expensive after seeing those perfectly
fresh flowers tossed at the end of her
wedding night Denise Samir came up with
the idea for bloomer n a mutual friend
introduced her to julia Cavallino who
quickly joined the business we share our
cars we share our clothing we even share
our beds
Airbnb so why not your you know event
flowers especially when otherwise
they're just gonna end up in the trash I
love flowers so this would be hard for
me but for a lot of Millennials they
love the idea of sharing he a minor is
editor-in-chief of Brides magazine when
you first heard about this idea what did
you think at first I thought I don't
know if every bride is gonna love the
idea sharing flowers but I quickly
realize for some people it is not
one of their biggest priorities and if
they can save money any way possible
because weddings are so expensive you
know it's worth a shot
and for those wedding guests hoping to
go home with a centerpiece in hand I
come from a family where they leave an
hour early to make sure that they leave
with the centerpieces when I got married
I know my mom was saying well aunt
Betty's getting the centerpiece and aunt
Evelyn's getting this one so but if you
knew you're gonna save $2,000 because
the florist is picking up your
centerpieces I think you might have said
and Betty I'll buy you some roses you
got to look out for Aunt Betty you may
be wondering how bloom rent makes money
it earns a fee every time a customer
books an event with a bloom rent florist
they're already in many regions across
the country but des neat who says she's
a second event bride and Julia who says
she's definitely a first Eventbrite are
looking to expand in the next few months
to Chicago San Francisco in Miami Wow
this was the hardest part of my wedding
saying goodbye to those flowers right
great they're thinking of another look
at title bloom red are you a first event
bride yes what does that mean again yeah
so you get to to get the fresh flowers
yes you get the fresh yet I'll be your
second we didn't write technology then
Yeah right yeah maybe the next wedding
maybe a baby shower I'm not announcing
anything I know you and Gail are already
committed I don't have a chance we'll be
right back